- J'ai besoin de reprendre ma
vie... là où est-ce qu'une
personne me l'a otée il y a 3
ans.
- Michelle souffre depuis qu'on
lui a installé une bandelette
sous l'urètre, un dispositif
médical pour traiter
l'incontinence urinaire.
Elle ne crée pas de problème
chez la grande majorité des
femmes, mais dans environ 10%
des cas, des complications
surviennent.
MICHELLE LIBOIRON
-Je ne peux plus m'asseoir les
jambes croisées, je ne peux plus
jouer avec mes petits-enfants.
On ne peut plus marcher.
-Il faut parfois même retirer
complètement la bandelette, une
opération délicate et invasive.
Québec a déployé en mars quatre
nouveaux centres de référence
pour traiter ce problème et
éventuellement, retirer
complètement les bandelettes.
Il s'agit du Centre hospitalier
universitaire de Montréal, de
SHerbooke, de Québec et le
consortium McGill. Michelle n'a
pas réussi à obtenir un rendez-
vous dans l'un de ces centres.
- J'ai cherché sur Internet.
J'ai laissé un message à un
numéro , j'ai jamais eu de
retour d'appel...
- Pourtant, le ministère de la
Santé confirme que les quatre
centres de référence sont en
fonction. En 2019, l'émission
Enquête avait diffusé des
témoignages de femmes opérées
par médecins québécois, qui
affirmaient leur avoir
complètement retiré
complètement leurs bandelettes.
Toujours souffrantes, ces femmes
se sont rendues aux États-Unis
où un chirurgien leur a enlevé
des bouts de bandelettes encore
restantes. Après ces reportages,
le Collège des médecins
recommande à Québec, d'ouvrir
des centres de références pour
traiter les femmes ici et que
les médecins soient bien formés
pour faire des retraits
complets. Le Collège demande
également au ministère de la
Santé de rembourser les femmes
qui se  rendent aux États-Unis
pour faire retirer complètement
leurs bandelettes.
CELINE DANIS
- Je suis allée là avec beaucoup
d'ouverture... mais les réponses
qu'on m'a données m'ont déçue,
je dirais...
- Céline s'est récemment rendue
au centre de référence de
Québec,où on lui a dit qu'elle
ne pourrait recevoir tous les
services dont elle a besoin.
- Pour la physiothérapie, on m'a
aussi conseillé d'aller au
privé, parce qu'en ce moment,
dans les centres d'expertise, il
n'y a pas de physiothérapeute
qui sont prêts à soigner les
femmes.
- Une information que confirme
l'Association des urologues. Un
seul centre de servicesest
complètement opérationnel au
Québec, celui du CHUM à
Montréal.
ALAIN MAILLETTE. Prés. Ass.  des
urologues du Québec
- Ce dossier-là devait être mis
en place en avril 2021.
Évidemment avec la pandémie,
comme on le sait, ce n'est pas
nécessairement évident non plus.
C'est pas évident, il y a des
retards dans les cliniques
externes, il y a des retards en
salle d'opération...
- L'Association des urologues
est claire : les femmes qui ont
besoin d'être opérées ici le
seront. Des urulogues et des
gynécologues font des retraits
complets de bandelette, mais en
équipe, parfois même à trois
chirurgiens.
- On nous a demandé de
développer l'expertise au Québec
et c'est ce qu'on fait
conjointement avec la
gynécologie.
- Ces opérations en équipe font
peur à Nathalie Robinson qui
s'est rendue au centre de
référence de Sherbrooke. Elle a
l'impression, comme d'autres
femmes, que les médecins se
regroupent par manque
d'expérience et d'habileté.
NATHALIE ROBINSON
- J'ai l'impression vraiment
qu'ils nous utilisent comme des
cobayes...
- Même constat pour Céline.
- Je n'attends plus après les
centres d'expertise. Je vais
plutôt probablement me tourner
vers, en retrait, aux États-
Unis.
- Avant l'ouverture des centres
en mars, Québec a remboursé les
frais médicaux de 155 femmes,
pour un montant total de
3.5 millions $. Une cinquantaine
d'autres femmes espèrent être
remboursées.
Ici Nancy Caouette,
Radio-Canada, M